hello and welcome to this video playing
whom as Kashia wave 54 okay all right
let's go
sideline against us laugh
you
so no slav then
Blackshirts basically try and it is a
bit earlier I think
I mean it's not a charity
yeah but he should try to wait until I
have committed with b3 with this push I
think this is a bit more comfortable for
white yes yeah then you know the story I
never understand there was kind of like
evening this is a super important
decision if you how you capture and he
hit he made it immediately
see if blacks like a surviving this well
if he is getting
kick it already
it's not going to be easy
[Music]
seven
he will survive e5 just barely
all right so but I have some other
things half 90 to do six one thing
nine day five
and Bishop III in some cases
I can also just take I'm not sure that
is a very simplistic approach and it
could be that it is just a bit
and just not cutting it you know dancing
and this is assistant exchange come on
yeah he had to go see Freud
okay now let's have a quick look now
that
take
can I mean I want to win immediately not
have some kind of game
still possible okay let's take it
rooty - threatens f4 though I want to
get in there for f4 and e5
you
hmm there's no Quincy fire unfortunately
but e5 is fine yeah I can take h7
you
[Music]
it ain't over til it's over or what it
sir what is it but hmm I think that's it
yeah just move Queenie Jade
when h h is is the game
okay queen h8
[Music]
you're just moving the Lucas probably
correct
how do we do this
you
oh I can actually do this chick cake
chick
you three trap submission
and if he moves the King I'm going
whoopty wrong
be too much really
oh maybe I can trap the bishop anyway
never looked in one is so good enough
it's really good enough
you
Oh
where is the mate
give me the mate
before we should be six check I don't
know it's not a maid but it's enough
still don't see the meat probably making
a complete fool out of myself here don't
see don't see the checkmate
thankfully it is just so uh so
completely winning that it doesn't
matter all that much
still don't see a mean
it's truly hard it's really hard that I
don't see a maid
you
we really strange
I mean
some just don't see it and I should
ah
you
yeah that should have been a woman long
ago and somehow it didn't find a kill
like real kill
well there's just one chick or something
we'd be one
you
it is increment
game
no Gabi I didn't find him me down I was
funny
yeah okay so Quincy to again I don't
think if five is particularly bad here
but it is usually better for black to
wait one for example to play something
like this so that after let's say I go
before I would have done that but let's
say I do that that black can actually
play this and this is fine so you just
wait for one move and if efore is not
great I have to do something some prep
move and that would be probably be three
or t1 and then you can see we consider
for example after b3 in a situation like
that again 95s not a good movement then
this is an idea so I think this is a bit
too early
yeah so we had all the trades and I took
and now he took with the night
immediately and it is wrong you know
after this is such an important decision
after C takes I might be better
strategically but this this can be
directly can be a direct problem there's
this they have to do you have to check
this because I get Tempe 9410 power
would be one it could be immediately bad
it seems that the engine doesn't see
much for me but it's just at the type of
decision that should take like say 10
seconds not one okay Bishop f6 and now I
went to here for grabbing in the center
and maybe hoop t1 is stronger but okay
let's do that
Knight b6 night before seems to better
I'm mostly interested in in why I hadn't
didn't really see her
okay yes ago c5 I thought what he said I
mean it's I wanted to do this and I
thought I'm better but it must be better
than b5 at least some okay this this
take take f4 okay
well I didn't see why I saw I mean what
I did saw is that but I didn't see a win
here
it was my issue
the engine doesn't see we neither yes so
ok then ripped it to is just a good move
let's keep everything interesting g5
that makes a lot of sense prevent a
fourth very good move
it's a very good move
okay with the exchange up I should win
this in the long run but that's not so
easy now
he allowed f4 and all this and the check
and this book DD one was better
okay a nice I liked the sequence but it
wasn't the best
it's always plus everything but there
was no maid there was really no wait I
was just sitting there thinking okay
there must be like a maid into that I
didn't see me okay this is not best
obviously but it's enough to win hmm I
could actually doesn't really mind my
plane ya know then it will fit loss was
okay I was really kind of expecting to
have missed mates in one made in two
whatever but I didn't okay guys thanks
for watching